[Musique]
l’époque du noir et blanc est peut-être
révolue au cinéma mais pas sur nos
routes où les véhicules blancs noirs
gris et argent volent la vedette il
représente aujourd'hui environ 80% des
voitures neuves en Amérique du Nord dans
les années 90 le verre était en tête il
a été dépassé par le gris au tournant du
siècle puis par le blanc dans les années
2010 ce qui fait dire à certains
spécialistes de l'automobile que la
popularité du blanc est due à l'effet
Apple avec l'arrivée de ses appareils à
l'esthétique épurées la couleur
influence-t-elle la valeur de revente
d'une voiture le site américain
Icard a évolué la dépréciation de plus
de 650 000 véhicules résultats les
couleurs rares comme le jaune et
l'oranger affecte le moins la valeur de
revente parce qu'elles sont souvent
associées à des éditions spéciales par
contre le doré prestigieux pour certains
fait perdre plus rapidement sa valeur à
une voiture même chose pour le brun
si vous trouvez les routes plus ternes
aujourd'hui c'est parce que les blancs
gris et noirs étendent leur suprématie
depuis 20 ans de quoi réjouir les héros
d'autrefois
[Musique]